so it looks like the filming for
spider-man far from home has begun today
we saw our first photos of Tom Holland
walking on the set of spider-man far
from home real quick be sure to hit that
subscribe button with the notifications
turned on if you want to stay up-to-date
on spider-man far from home this was
taken and Stortford England which is
where most of the filming is said to be
taking place unfortunately all of the
filming that is taking place at this
location is all inside so we only have
photos of Tom Holland walking to the set
and unfortunately nothing of him on the
set as spider-man but one thing that is
apparent is that Spidey is definitely
alive after the events of infinity war
I think it's everybody's guess and
assumption right now that by the end of
Avengers 4 all of our heroes will be
brought back to life somehow there's
been a lot of talk about plot leagues
for a spider-man far from home but
unfortunately nothing has really been
confirmed yet it was originally thought
that Spiderman was on a school field
trip but this has recently been debunked
by Marvel president himself Kevin Feige
Kevin Feige came out and stated that
spider-man is not on a school trip but
he's actually on vacation we do know
that Mysterio will be one of the
villains and vulture is coming back as
well Jake Gyllenhaal has been rumored to
play Mysterio but nothing has been
confirmed yet there's really not too
much you can take from these photos as
it's just Tom Holland walking onto the
set and it's not actually in the set but
it's really exciting that filming has
begun because once filming starts
usually true leaks up here like if jake
gyllenhaal will be spotted on set then
we know he's playing Mysterio and the
big question will Tony Starks they'll be
in the movie and if we spot Robert
Downey jr. on set that's probably a go
although I am quite certain that if
Robert Downey jr. is in this movie as
Tony Stark they will do whatever they
can from keeping fans from noticing
because if anybody finds out that he's
in that movie that means we note that he
survives Avengers 4 and there's no way
that they're going to let us know that
so those are the photos of the first
spotting of Tom Holland on the set
for spider-man far from home although
the movie doesn't come out until a year
from now let me know what you're most
excited about please hit the like button
and subscribe to my channel so you could
stay up to date on spider-man far from
home and Avengers 4 thank you so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you
[Music]